it's real delicious you're gonna like it
too
i got problems i'm sorry i've been
locked up too long cabin fever
what's up everybody i'm david and you
know i love to cook but only on a budget
we've made a romantic steak dinner for
two fourteen dollars i made brunch for
some friends for twenty dollars
now that it's summer time i wanted to
get a little creative so today i'm gonna
try to make a dollar dish
picnic for two for only fourteen dollars
will i be able to make it happen
will you all laugh at me in the comments
let's find out
well everybody this is the hall looks
pretty good to me we've
got a wide variety of stuff to make an
amazing summer picnic here we actually
came in under budget
while we were looking to spend only 14
we spent 13.37
now along with all of this we're going
to use some of our pantry staples today
we're going to use flour sugar olive oil
salt and pepper
i'm really excited to get to it so let's
go ahead and jump into the first recipe
all right so to get started we're going
to make a fresh corn salad
now this is a great addition to have
because corn is inexpensive it's in
season right now
and it's a nice delicious hearty side to
have now the first thing we're going to
do is pickle some onions
we're going to do that with a little bit
of olive oil some lemon juice
a little bit of salt real quick just a
little half one and then of course some
sugar in there the pickling of the
onions is going to do two things for us
take out a little bit of that bite
because it can be a little strong so
that it just blends better with
everything in case you don't like that
and we didn't have enough money to buy
vinegar so it's going to help us make a
little salad dressing as well
all right this is looking pretty good
and the next thing we're going to do is
boil our corn so we're going to bring
some salted water to a boil
and place the corn in there for just
about five minutes some people tend to
overcook their corn boiling it for 10 or
15 minutes
you can always tell if you've left it in
too long if it starts to wrinkle
now you can eat corn raw so honestly all
you need is about five or so minutes and
you'll be good to go
all right now that our corns finish
boiling we're gonna go ahead and cut it
and prep it to go into our salad you
also want to make sure that you don't
handle them until they're cool to the
touch
so you don't burn yourself typically
when people cut corn you'll see them
stand it up like this
but i'm going to recommend that you go
ahead and just lay it on its side
and the paper towel will help you keep
it stabilized and it's also going to
help catch those kernels so they don't
fly everywhere
whenever i'm cooking and stuff's flying
everywhere it gets on my nerves i know
you probably feel the same
so you're going to go ahead and just
very carefully
cut down the sides and if we're lucky
we'll get some nice little pieces like
this that we can put into our bowl
now that the corn is done we'll add some
fresh tomatoes even got a little avocado
on the budget you know on the lookout
for you
our pickled onions a little bit of salt
a little pepper
now mix all that together and then
transfer it into a bowl for a backyard
picnic or tupperware so you can have it
on the go
we're just going to drizzle a little bit
of olive oil on there put a nice
little pie out of salt on there and of
course
get a little fresh ground pepper and
that is our fresh tomato corn salad it's
colorful
filling and refreshing now it's time to
spice things up let's go ahead and move
on to our main course
and now i'm going to make a spicy fried
chicken it's a delicious hearty addition
travels well and is delicious at room
10. we're going to go ahead and get
started with a nice two ingredient
marinade here i'm gonna take my hot
sauce
and put it into the sour cream and then
just gonna whisk it together
now we're gonna use sour cream instead
of buttermilk because it's a little bit
cheaper
and it's still gonna give us that nice
little tang now that that's mixed
together
we're going to go ahead and season our
chicken we're going to take a little bit
of salt we're using chicken thighs
with the bone in as well as having the
skin on because that's going to be a
little bit cheaper
and the dark meat always provides a
really nice flavor and a little bit of
pepper for these
now that we've got these all seasoned
we're gonna go ahead and transfer them
into our marinade make sure you get
every piece nicely coated
i'm gonna go ahead and cover this with
some plastic wrap and let it marinate in
the fridge for about one to two hours
if you have more time you can let it
marinate overnight now it's time to fry
some chicken
so as you can see we've got our
marinated chicken that we were working
on earlier
and a little bit of flour now sometimes
you want to add a little kick but you
don't have all the money to get all the
various spices you'll need
so we found a seasoning packet this
one's a buffalo flavor to add just a
little bit more heat a little bit of a
kick to it
so what we're going to do is tear that
open
and put just a little bit to the side
you know about a teaspoon or something
because we want to use that later so
that we can garnish our chicken
and go ahead and put the rest of it into
your flour and you're going to mix
that up i'm going to go ahead and take
these
beautiful chicken thighs you're going to
put them directly into your flour
you want to dredge them in the flour and
make sure that they get evenly coated
now being that i'm from the south my mom
used to have me do this in a brown paper
bag we just throw the flour in there
shake it up and make sure you cover
everything nicely you're going to go
directly from that flour carefully place
it into the oil
as you can see we've got a cast iron
skillet
that's going to allow us to do a shallow
fry save a little bit more of the oil we
bought and
that retains heat amazingly works really
well we're going to get a really nice
crisp on our chicken
we've heated up our oil to about 350 or
so degrees
we're going to let these bad boys fry
we're only going to do about two at a
time here because we want to make sure
we don't crowd the pan
because if you add too much chicken
you're not going to have enough time to
cook evenly and give you that nice crisp
that you're looking for
all right now that we're finished we're
going to go ahead
and let these drain on a paper towel and
while they're still hot
we're going to use that leftover
seasoning we had and go ahead and
garnish with a little bit of that put a
little extra dry rub and love on there
and put a little extra on mine all right
now that we're finished
we're going to go ahead and place these
in a little basket put them in a box
whatever is clever and with that we have
our flavorful spicy fried chicken
i know amanda is going to love this now
you got to keep the spice in the kitchen
and in your relationship that's another
tip now let's end things on a sweet note
with dessert
today we're gonna make some strawberry
shortcake jars and strawberry shortcake
is refreshing and
i mean why not so i got lucky and found
these mini biscuits for only a dollar
which is perfect because that's all i
really need for the two of us we'll go
ahead
open it up it's my favorite part and
we've got a baking sheet
lined with parchment paper help us to
make sure they don't stick when we take
them out
we're just going to put these into the
oven and follow the directions on the
can
it says about 400 degrees for 8 to 11
minutes or until they're nice and golden
brown on the top let's go pop these in
the oven
now another reason we're making
strawberry shortcake is that we found
these strawberries on sale for only a
dollar and 56 cents for an entire pound
now i want to show you a little trick
that we used when we prepped our
strawberries
if you can take a metal straw like this
and insert it through the bottom
then the stem just pops right out if you
have a little excess that's all right
just tear it off and then you'll chop it
and throw it in there with the rest you
want to make sure to drizzle with just a
little bit of sugar
to make it a little sweet and it's going
to bring out the juices in the
strawberries when we add it to our jar
it'll make a nice little strawberry
syrup for those biscuits to soak up
all right our biscuits are ready first
we're going to chop up these biscuits
now i recommend taking it and kind of
trying to cut it in half first
then laying it flat cutting across
spinning it one more time and that'll
give you some nice little bite-sized
cubes throw those into a bowl
we've got these really cool glass jars
which are going to be perfect for after
we assemble everything so you can see
all the beautiful layers
now you're going to start out with your
chopped biscuits then we'll add our
strawberries
you want to try to work from the outside
layer in and then we're going to add
the whipped cream now you don't have to
use a piping bag but
i think it's kind of cool pretty easy
and i wanted to feel fancy
so we'll just squeeze that in there it's
a little bit messy so i'm just going to
smooth that out
i'm going to go ahead and add some more
of our biscuits and for me
it doesn't have to look pretty as long
as it tastes good some more of our fresh
strawberries on there
we'll end with our whipped topping
we're going to put just a little bit of
our biscuits on top as a little garnish
and a nice little strawberry on the side
now these strawberry shortcake jars
actually get even better the longer they
sit because that strawberry syrup is
just gonna sop and soak into those
biscuits and make it even more amazing
it's the perfect picnic dessert because
they look taste and smell just like
summer
well everyone this is our dollar dish
picnic for two and we were able to
execute it for
under fourteen dollars we've got a fresh
corn tomato salad
we've got some delicious spicy fried
chicken and our strawberry shortcake jar
now uh before i go i gotta make sure and
do some quality control let's see how
this
came out
that's good that extra little seasoning
on top gave it the perfect little kick
i gotta wrap all this up take it home me
and amanda are gonna have a backyard
picnic
i'll see you next time make sure you
subscribe
[Music]
you